ciao solita visita in italia nei rossi
andremo a vedere altre trasformazioni di
capelli altre tinte cappelle
trasformazioni colori pazzi perché
l'altro piaciuto tantissimo anche a me
ci ha divertito tantissimo vederci
trasformazioni quindi non vediamo l'ora
di vederne altre assieme a voi lasciate
un bel live se volete vederne altre
ancora iscriversi pure i miei commenti
di che colore abiti cappelli materico i
popcorn tv subito beh allora prima
trasformazione abbiamo biondi signora
diventeranno più una o anche peggio che
tira è abbinato al trucco infatti tra
l'altro sembra un viola scuro no sembra
un volatile un viola chiaro mette i
guanti infatti arrivati visto mi chiamo
diventato un rosa praticamente il
prossimo abbiamo un altro biondo perché
nel mondo che funzionano messi
andremo a dire di coloro arechi mi
affascina e natura che complicata questa
è una treccia a spina di pesce dover mai
riuscito a farle troppo di bissina
sangua ma questo era solo una
pettinatura
colore infatti bellissimo massimo
abbiamo un rosa chiaro che lo desiderano
questo colore sta facendo le sfumature
vuol vedere no strano perché mettono
trasparente ravanello pallido
ero un po complicato ma forse una
pettinatura questa era uno spazzolino
questo potere di trucco per togliere i
capelli svolazzante si consolino con un
po di lacca
ma dai adesso problema è quello di
vedere come diventa ha fatto dei boccoli
need avanti del carini parte vediamo qua
strause domeniche tinge i capelli al
bimbo no non penso così no no no ragazzi
non si può non è non va bene di ricerca
per caso sei troppo piccoli passaggi
ventesima rover ed i suoi sono più scuri
che le del bambino bello il colore se un
bellissimo aveva già dei capelli
bellissimi quindi voglio più vedere come
diventano adesso è la una sfumatura sul
biondo credo che farà
una sorta di sfumatura grigia bellissimi
però sta la bianca piccolo con me stava
meglio prima
questa è una acconciatura provenienza
c'è questa cosa che è un boccone o come
si chiama la fiom bellino per chiudere o
che bello
dai non è fare mentre quelli che viene
bene che voglia di fare tre senso che
aveva nello stesso mese il canone
mensile dell'attacco delle forze dopo
togliere il spero che tolga via grotta
così non si vede ma deve coprire che per
fino ad ora hanno fatto un'altra filosi
mario fales al nome di ciuffetti non uno
che passerà imparati quindi faccio un
prato un orto vi faccia in testa i tanti
nodi sembrano che prossimo colore
a quanto pare i viola va molto di moda
lo slime sembrava alla ragazza di prima
quindi restano molto di moda quest'anno
viola lilla farle più scure matitone
viola e grigio sono i colori di
quest'anno
qua siamo gli faccio anch'io così taglio
voglio è sempre bello dovete vendere un
po meno un altro viola viola li stanno
facendo quasi uno shampoo colorato
solita penso serva le ronde colorante
forza 2 unleashed anche perché ce
l'aveva terricci prima
oggi macchina però per adesso non molto
belli anche adesso super docenti
bellissimo strano per la tagliano mentre
alla cosap rescono benissimo un'altra
vita
vediamo le punte di che colore blu
forfait fa ridere come un pacchetto da
gaza perché non lavorando da tempo si
sono già bellissima non c'è bisogno di
fare altro che un po distratta fare
proprio questo allora prossima
trasformazione abbiamo dei capelli
biondissimi lista fosse un arcobaleno
che bella striscia
wow chissà se riesce a prendere pure la
sfumatura ha fatto fa tenerli così il
dritto di tipo ci ha messo un prodotto
agli apporti di bordo
fantastico sfuma tumore
wow non avevo mai visto una finta così
da un lato dall'altro massimo abbiamo
capito che
decolorante che cosa che non risolvo io
voler rotto wow proprio vedere come sono
una volta tutti wow bello stop alle 18
guarda che su mosquera pazzesca è
fighissimo
abbiamo capelli biondissimi che cosa ora
abbiamo un ottimo visto che usa la
tecnica o bros
le cose vediamo come diventare asciutti
verdi e tipo parliamo verde acqua no
perché animale
[Musica]
[Applauso]
il mondo sembra parlato perché sono solo
delle strisce di arcobaleno allora qua
sta mettendo la tinta a strisce in un
pezzo visco tricks sembra non so poi
come wow che questa copa nero ma che ha
fallito presso una nota è sotto al con
palermo ritorno davvero di capelli ogni
costo anche corvia un mille solo allora
la radice mera no forse una grossa blu e
verde viola
oh che bello vediamo il risultato
arancione che bello di how to pelli
davvero capelli unicorno a 0 quando li
colorano di tutti i colori e questo più
bello allora viola chiaro o del
colorante decolorante sera tecnico lo
vedi segno rosso acceso
no mi sembra un fucsia sì ma autrice
anche questo ma che figata bellissimi
all'arpa era loro il muro che
trasformazione
tutti belli ma adesso lo stanno mettendo
con a caldo di coristi attaccano assurdo
ma ottiene molti lunghissimi corto ha
sempre la stessa
no non mi sento burro da pesca lista
colorano ancora prima fatto biondo poi
rosa adesso viola wow di una super
accesso violenza anno io voglio fare
anch'io viola e giallo per amore passo
puria fatti bianchi silvers ultimo
argento che belli capelli argentati amo
ha forse fatto allo stesso da sfumature
striscia vediamo cortissimi
le visite ormai famosa perché lo sta
seguendo per farlo più chiaro forse per
fare questo effetto fatti che cola
effetto mi è caduta la lenta sui capelli
la forza perché così riescono più
sfumature si è però anche bello stare lì
con la molto più chiaro di fatti belli
si veda un po di biondo soc
questi sono biondissima a foto musica lo
riguardano andavano prime per
comprendere ciò che tutti i colori
pastello verde viola blu
wow belli sia per il coraggio di
pazienti colore arcobaleno tra
bellissimo che gli ha detto ieri era
bello quando fanno questa cosa così dire
scala
vediamo come fichi colore diventeranno
presto b2 colorati e infatti biondi
sfuma 30 al biondo a silver argento
vediamo come l'onore di norma solo non
mi piace mi piace tantissimo questo
forse non le fanno molto bene
posizionare in lei dall'arcobaleno non
capisco che cos'è quella cosa che
mettono sotto sembra di buon force one
questo colore mi piace tantissimo
secondo voi ne sarebbe bene questo rosso
supera acceso
a me piace fallo di mano che beh perché
sembra così mi mogano
un po viola grigio colorato da guerra fa
un'altra sfumatura arcobaleno queste
sono carine loro paese ci vuole tanta
pazienza ma che belli troppo bello
l'effetto cappai unicorno io quella
com'erano prima non superi crescita di
un po come li trasforma tagli agli shock
molto zone scoloriti sta facendo tutto
svolgerlo come avevano paura cappello o
incredibile stupendo allora viola rosa
arancione forse anche quasi sarà un
membro l'amico saleno vediamo viola rosa
vediamo un risultato è che belli i
colori rientra volto poi con i boccoli
[Musica]
vertici nei commenti il minuto della
trasformazione che vi è piaciuta di più
in assoluto ma questo fatto forse questa
con
i capelli blu e arcobaleno bellissima
adesso più belle è che se volete vederne
altri e ora vi lasciamo 4 casa dire su
cui cliccare cliccando su quella che
preferite
ebbene mischiare ciao